allah talks about how he's going to pull
or how our souls are going to be pulled
out through the english translation i
said i have says through our forelocks
right through our foreheads through
they're going to be ripped out
[Music]
no no if he does not desist we will
surely drag him by the forelock
for a believer it's just a little
perspiration perspiration
with my functional neurology
where what area now do you think science
should support religion and your
religion should support your science
they're if they're right
where do you think you make that final
decision whether you just do something
or you inhibit that bad action
that's the forehead that's the frontal
lobes that's the forelock that's the
brain
there's no way we knew that 1500 years
ago
i mean remember just a few hundred years
ago
people thought women didn't have a brain
they thought that you know the
christians didn't think women had a soul
forever right
i mean here's the quran 1500 years ago
or so
telling us
that
this is
where you're going to be punished from
or pulled out through when you're a bad
guy
and that's that's your final inhibition
that's your final initiation of the good
or bad you decide to do it's the
forehead it's the forelock so
it's really science religion it all
agrees
for me
people wondered is there something
different about the brain
of somebody who does violent acts
particularly repetitive violent acts
in comparison to an ordinary person's
brain
but not very much was known about it
until the last maybe 15 20 years
particularly as we entered the era of
the
magnetic resonance imaging
front part of the brain called the
orbital frontal
cortex
the
that area
is involved in moral decision making
in
figuring out what's right versus what's
wrong that we learn as we grow up and
are instructed by our parents and our
teachers
so
if that area of the brain is not
operating at full tilt
it may be possible then to carry out an
act which would be repugnant and very
much against the law
of the biological roots of crime he's
narrowed in on a part of the brain
called the prefrontal cortex one of its
primary roles is moderating social
behavior is a normal individual with
good frontal lobe functioning
here's an example of the 42 murderers we
had you can see a distinct lack of
activation
in that prefrontal cortex that's the
emergency
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not yet muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the quran go and visit the show.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum and if you like this episode of
the deen show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum